we really suffering big losses and
Ukraine which were feeding South Africa
and many other African countries
supplying grain and actually
today we cannot do it because our
country is at War and South Africa is
making a friendly kind of arrangements
with Russia which basically invaded our
country
I would tell him to stop lying because
he is the the main liar for Putin and
their regime and to stop trying to
deceive everybody in the world as to
what they are doing in Ukraine and what
their purpose is
and to admit that there is it's nothing
else but a genocidal colonial war on the
Ukrainian people and to stop it and to
immediately would withdraw all their
troops and most of all stop cowardly
bombing
our hospitals and our schools and
apartment blocks
[Applause]
we are all in favor in favor of uh
peaceful resolution of disputes and uh
will be will be always ready to discuss
negotiated solution to any conflict on
Earth unfortunately most of the
conflicts launched by our
Western colleagues
did not lead to any Improvement in the
situation and this is
something which the world inherited as
regards the specific situation between
us and Ukraine
it is well known that we supported the
proposal of Ukrainian side
to negotiate
early in the in the special military
operation and by the end of March in
Istanbul two delegations agreed on the
principles to settle this conflict it is
well known it was published uh openly
that our American and British and some
European colleagues told Ukraine that it
is too early to deal and the the
arrangement which was almost agreed uh
was never Revisited by the Keith regime